you
[Music]
so just a quick introduction to myself
thank you for the introduction Pete I've
been working with databases for a couple
of decades first as a developer and
after a few years of developing software
and then discovering that I loved
databases more I started writing on my
blog about pretty much everything that I
was learning about and that got me the
opportunity to co-author this book and
then I joined the co-authors of that
book in their company Percona so I was a
database consultant for four or five
years something like that through the
fast growth period of MySQL and web 2.0
and so I got to consult alongside a
bunch of really interesting customers
who were pushing what MySQL could do a
lot of that was around the internal
limitations of MySQL in particular some
of you know that the internal code of
the database rather than the code that
people were running in the database and
that led me to understand a
performance-based mindset and after a
while I started writing tools around
that most of it is open source so it's a
Prachanda toolkit it's you know table
it's we're kind of monitoring plugins
now so this is all open source software
that I wrote some of which is still
widely used today but after a while I
realized this could be turned into a
product or these ideas could be turned
into a product so I left Percona and
founded a company called vivid cortex
and we do database performance
monitoring essentially for some of the
similar kinds of use cases you know if
you have large-scale MySQL Postgres and
you don't measure it which I can say
with probably 99% certainty you don't
measure what it's doing then we are a
great way to measure that at any scale
with essentially zero performance
overhead so that's kind of you know my
background and where we are today the
company is 5 or 6 years old I've stepped
down as CEO recently hired a new CEO and
I'm CTO so I get to focus a lot more on
the technology and spend a lot more time
in product with customers which is great
these slides are going to be online I've
got an introduction slide here I'm going
to skip past because that's for people
who are viewing the slides online so
what are we going to talk about today
this is about quantifying system
scalability and it
much simpler than it sounds if you
understand how to sort of approach it in
a productive way we'll start with a
typical way that a lot of people do this
which is through the science of computer
performance as the utilization and
response time are related to each other
and this is a great place to start
because it's where a lot of the existing
literature is and I'll kind of explore
that for a little bit and then we'll
pivot over into starting to define what
scalability means from a similar kind of
mathematical perspective there's no need
for any mathematical knowledge here what
I really want to do is just build
intuition through all of these things
after that will extend Amdahl's law into
the universal scalability law which is a
relatively recent articulation of the
math of how systems scale and then we'll
see how to apply that in the real world
using one of our servers that I just
grabbed some data from last night is
kind of a desk test data set and then
we'll see what kinds of interesting
things we can do with that and my goal
is for you to have some takeaways that
you can go home and apply this to your
own systems or maybe even you know just
here this afternoon because it's quite
simple it's kind of spreadsheet sort of
math and that's that's what we'll talk
about today so let's start with queueing
theory and this is actually the math you
just nerdiest part of it because this is
about a century-old discipline and
there's a lot of complexity here it
turns out to that there's a queueing
theory is basically probability and
probability is really really complicated
to understand and apply and so what I'm
going to try and do is skim around the
things that are the most useful and give
you some foundation for maybe going
deeper on queueing theory if you want to
but then I'm also going to kind of do a
bait-and-switch at the end and get out
of queuing theory so queueing theory is
this branch of operations research it
started with telecommunications capacity
planning and genome Dahl was sorry I'm
completely it's not genome Dahl
and I'm forgetting Oh Erlang ignore
Erlang was trying to answer the question
how many telephone lines do I need to
have to give people the ability to place
a call with a certain amount of waiting
online for a circuit to open up and what
he discovered has turned into this rich
set of theory and practice that's useful
in all kinds of things like how many
lines do we need open you know how many
cash registers do we need open at the
shopping centers so that people don't
have to wait too long in line to check
out their groceries things like that
it's all kinds of waiting analysis and
it turns out that probability is a
really important part of that which is
what makes it both interesting and hard
so what causes things to wait is
basically irregularity of jobs jobs
arrive at a system and they take some
amount of time to be processed and when
they arrive irregularly or when there
are too many of them to fit into the
available time for processing then this
time gets lost because of overlapping
jobs and this has really
counterintuitive kind of explosive
behavior and a queue is what you place
in front of a system to make it more
available if you don't have a queue than
if a job arrives at a system and there's
another job in process then it's
unavailable and the job has to fail if
it doesn't have some place to wait then
you get max connections exceeded or some
some kind of a similar type of a
phenomenon but the system is not
available while another job is running
and this could be a request response in
a web server or a query to a database
root server or arriving at the checkout
line at the grocery store or whatever it
is because you wait in the queue it
increases how long you actually wait to
get your job done
so queues increase waiting and reduce a
response or increase response time and
it also increases the cost and overhead
of running the system so if we look at
something like a web server if you have
a queue in front of it or if we look at
the networking stack in the operating
system when you have a
in front of it it's one more thing that
has to be managed so it's not free to
have a queue but it does increase
availability and utilization by time
shifting things so that there's more
more ability for the system to have a
job ready to process when it is ready
I'm going to explain it graphically and
I've totally ripped this idea off from
Evan Freeman at honeycomb he did a
phenomenal job of visualizing this and
explaining kind of the essence of it so
I'm basically taking this whole section
of slides from him and I've got a link
to his slides at the end and his talk at
Lisa is on YouTube and all that stuff is
linked in the resources at the end of
the slides so we have some arrival rate
lambda and we have some job which is you
know this long in the timeline and it's
this high it's the same height in the
vertical size so it's kind of a
visualization that a job arrives and
it's this high and as time progresses it
gets worn down or used up or you know
completed and so we get a triangle with
a 45-degree slope and the server is
processing it during that time so the
upper edge of that triangle at any
moment in time is the amount of work
left to do and when that gets down to
zero then the job is done what happens
when another request arrives and the
first one is still in process well we
get a a red parallelogram and when the
first job is done then the second one
has another gray another great rying
--gel and here I'm going to introduce
just a little bit of the queueing
notation so R is the residence time
response time you can also call it
latency but R is the the letter that I
will use pretty uniformly for this not
only in this presentation but just
that's the the letter that I use for
this and R is composed of two things
first there's s the service time so
that's the time that it takes for the
job to actually run that's the time that
it takes for the cashier to actually do
your groceries for example and then
there's W the waiting time component and
you add those two together and get your
total time to checkout or you get your
total time for the
we're here to execute or whatever it is
and so that's that's kind of a really
fundamental thing in queueing theory
analysis and if we have multiples of
these things you can see how the cues
kind of pile up maybe requests even
stack on top of each other in the queue
and Emin does this really clever thing
where he uses a little bit of math I'm
not going to go through it here but you
can watch us talk and see how it's done
to relate the vertical and horizontal
dimensions here and derive this equation
now this is an equation that can be
derived multiple ways but this is a
really cool intuitive visual way to do
this and you solve for W the wait time
and that is the wait time in the queue
it's not the total response time and you
get this this formula which is related
in terms of how long it takes a job to
be done and how fast they arrive which
is essentially another way to state how
busy the server is going to be
processing those jobs and then I've
drawn a picture of what the curve of
that looks like I've translated it into
the utilization domain which is
typically how you dilute out queueing
theory is is formulated is response time
versus utilization rather than the
arrival rate so I'm just kind of trying
to relate that into something that might
be a little bit more familiar if you go
look at textbooks or whatever well you
get this hockey stick curve now warning
this hockey stick curves perspectives
the aspect ratio is highly skewed to
flatten it out it's actually a much
steeper than that but generally what
happens is as utilization increases and
gets close to 1 and utilization cannot
go higher than one fully utilized as as
full as the server can get suddenly the
response time spiked up dramatically
very dramatically and that is kind of
the fundamental take away from from
queueing theory what were one of the
fundamental takeaways from queueing
theory is that as systems get busier
they very non linearly get much less
responsive and customers have to wait
much much much longer the nice thing
about this way of formulating the
response time or the wait time equation
is that you can look at it
kind of Intuit some things from it very
easily so just as a thought experiment
if you were to double the arrival rate
and have the service time then what
happens is that the numerator becomes
half the size but the denominator
remains the same and so the queue weight
gets cut in half if you shrink the
service time so the queue weight is very
sensitive to the service time those
things are related to each other very
very closely and that's that's really
important other things that are very
related to the queue weight time are as
I mentioned a little bit earlier the
variability how much these things vary
in the frequency or the inter arrival
time is therefore how much they're going
to overlap because overlapping is what
contributes to that explosion in queue
weight so this is really good for
building intuition about how as you
start to push systems to their capacity
suddenly they start kind of pushing back
at you and everybody gets a miserable
experience who is a customer of this
system but the hard part is how you
actually translate this into practice
how do you go and use this in your
systems to figure out predict
performance understand how much capacity
you're going to need the the part of
this that's hard has actually turns out
to be measuring the service time and the
inter arrival times and understanding
that the statistical distribution of
those things and therefore which of many
queueing models to use for this what
I've shown you is kind of a gross
oversimplification but the intuition is
still valid the application is hard so
great kind of takeaways from that
intuition is that any system is going to
have some amount of queueing literally
any system queueing starts before the
system starts getting very busy at all
even if it's a small amount of queueing
it is there and it escalates really
suddenly you know not escalated fast and
it's very sensitive to the service time
and various kinds of variability and
then the thing that I'm going to say
that does not follow from anything that
I've said is that this causes non linear
scalability it is one of two causes of
nonlinear scalability and I'm
switch now I said rabbit out of the Hat
bait and switch I'm gonna switch into
that next and then I'll introduce the
other cause of nonlinear skill ability a
little bit later all right so let's
switch into a relationship called
Amdahl's law which is from genome Dahl
and it defines essentially how much do
things get faster as you paralyze them
there's a couple of ways that you can
tilt and rewrite this equation but
that's that's kind of the gist of it is
how much speed-up do you get from
parallelizing so this really starts to
define and get at the root of what
scalability is scalability is a function
of concurrency remember those triangles
stacked on top of each other when
there's one triangle there's concurrency
of one when you've got one stacked on
top waiting you've got concurrency of
two concurrency is a really fundamental
problem property of a systems workload
it turns out to be kind of the central
thing the the hub of the wheel from
which all of the spokes radiate in
performance theory one way or and other
concurrency is at the root of it I
talked about utilization utilization is
just concurrency of the server itself so
there's a mathematical definition of
scalability that follows from
concurrency concurrency is also the
canonical definition of system load so
we can think of scalability in terms of
system load as well so I'm going to
illustrate one of these parallel
processing systems where we got some job
and we're gonna break it up into smaller
jobs so we've got a long job and then
there's three kind of sub components and
if we take those and run them in
parallel then their response time should
should shrink to one third of the the
original response time right and if it's
done faster than we can do more of them
we can get higher throughput we can get
a higher rate of completions over time
right so we're seeing a function here
that throughput is a function of
concurrency and that's kind of where
we're going with scalability ideal
linear scalability is precisely like
this picture on the right hand side here
if we can divide this into three equal
hearts then we can do three times as
many of them right so with concurrency
of three we will get three times the
throughput so now I'm starting to relate
concurrency on the bottom with
throughput on the the vertical axis and
that's you're gonna see me expand on
that a little bit more these are the two
fundamental dimensions of scalability so
this relationship is really important
and our deal scalability is linear
there's lots of marketing talk about
linear scalability when you do the math
on it just take some of the measurements
off of a benchmark plug them into a
spreadsheet and extrapolate out from the
first measurement you will see whether
it is linear or not so it's really easy
to figure out whether you've got truly
linear scalability or not all right so
so this is linear scalability and this
is this is our I deal a lot of times
people will think of linear scalability
and say something like you know linear
scalability doesn't imply that the
constant of scaling is one or some
similar kind of a phrase but beware of
that thinking because if one unit of
concurrency produces one unit of
throughput and two produces one times
two times a constant of scalability such
as 0.9 seven or something like that if
you actually follow that train of
thought to its logical conclusion you
will see that you do not get linear you
get a curve and in fact you will get I'm
dolls long curve which has an asymptote
which I'm going to show you in a few
minutes so don't don't accept a kind of
thinking that is you know that there's
some kind of sort of constant in there
that's less than one and it's still
still linear because it's not linear so
if we put this into an equation then we
get the slope of gamma and n is the the
unit of concurrency I'll also use that
very consistently that's the number of
things running at a time and and it's
all over one I didn't have to put it
over one but I'm gonna build on this
equation a little bit and you'll see how
I'm gonna chug some other things into
the bottom of that equation
all right so it's it's handy to start
with the one so X is the symbol for
throughput so X at a given n is equal to
some constant of slope of the line times
one I'm sorry divided by one but
unfortunately our cluster is never
perfect
if we can't subdivide those tasks evenly
or more importantly if there's a part
that can't be subdivided then we get
some serialized portion maybe at the
beginning maybe at the end maybe both
so I've notated that with gray here and
you see that now some portion of our
process might run three times as fast
but overall the whole process is not
going to run three times as fast and to
express that mathematically we can add
in another component onto the numerator
sorry the denominator of our equation
with a serialized fraction and I'm using
the universal scalability laws notation
of Sigma here for this serialized
fraction and that's the stuff that
starts to deteriorate scalability so
I've kind of shown what the curve looks
like kind of pulling away from the
linear scalability slope up to three
four four nodes so that's what it starts
to look like we start to level off and
eventually that line will approach an
asymptote serialization is queueing so
this is where I'm going to loop it back
into that first section this
serialization that's that's exactly what
queueing does queueing is when access to
a resource is restricted and you have to
wait in line that's the definition of
serialization so although these are in a
little bit different domains and it's a
little tough to actually make the
mathematical link between them I think
that's a career effort for for lots of
people at MIT and places like that we
won't go into that here but you know you
can just trust me that these these
different domains are actually linked
I mentioned that there's an apt
asymptote when we kind of take this
limit to infinity what happens if you
kind of cancel out and take the limit of
infinity you go to 1 over Sigma
everything else kind of disappears so
another way to say that is if we have 5%
serialisation then ultimately no matter
how small we subdivide that thing in the
middle
our task can't run faster than 5 percent
of the original total because that's the
serialized gray portions at the
beginning in the end and no matter how
many servers we use how many how much
parallelization we still only get
effectively a 20x speed-up if we have 5%
serialization so that that curve is
going to level off at the throughput of
20 times the slope all right so that's
am dollz law and hopefully you agree
with me that this is not going too deep
that we can all this is this is kind of
still in the realm of intuition we're
gonna add one more component on here
and see how this turns into a fuller
definition of scalability that we can
use so our cluster is not only imperfect
in that there's some serialized workload
but most kinds of clustered or parallel
processing systems also have some
interaction between the tasks and this
is deadly because when one of the
threads or processes has to coordinate
with another one ask it for some data
they both stop working on their job and
they start working on each other and
what this means is that as we subdivide
and increase the concurrency we're
actually adding a significant amount of
cost to the overall job of processing
our tasks and so I've notated that by
adding in orange and I've got the
original length of these tasks in the
dotted lines and then I've added as much
run time to the end as the orange takes
out of the middle because they had to
pause so the service time of these tasks
actually increases this is not queuing
because it's extra work that they're
doing they're not waiting idly in a
queue they're actively working and
typically making each other
work and this gets really bad really
really fast because the worst case is
that each task is asking all of the
other tasks to help it do something or
to do something for it and that
relationship explodes really fast the
worst case is that there's n times n
minus 1 pairs of interactions between
these tasks which grows order N squared
and I'm gonna take that n times n minus
1 and put another component in front of
it a fraction in front of it and put it
onto the bottom of M dolls law and so
when that happens I put Kappa that's our
coefficient but Kappa in front of n
times n minus 1 put it on the bottom of
this equation and we get the first full
view of the universal scalability law so
I called this crosstalk Neil Gunther who
created the universal scalability law
cause the coherence there's a couple of
other terms that will float around
coordination penalty and what happens is
that not only does our curve level off
and the aspect ratio of this diagram is
a little bit hard to see but it can
actually and will actually go downwards
so we get retrograde scalability and if
you think about this you've probably
seen this a lot in system benchmarks
many system benchmarks like like cluster
databases and things like that we'll
have a benchmark where they'll show you
the throughput of that system compared
to the number of workers or the number
of threads or something like that and
the stereotypical thing is that you will
have the number of workers and some
powers of two so you'll have like 1 2 4
8 16 up to let's say 256 so you have to
kind of be careful with looking at the
horizontal axis of those charts but what
you'll see is usually something that
goes up and then starts to slide again
and ideally it would just keep going up
a lot of vendors are really just trying
to stop the the degradation and show
that their system will flatten off and
then not deteriorate in performance past
some point but if you look at those and
you kind of translate that logarithmic
horizontal ax
you will see a curve that looks very
much like the blue curve here and that
nonlinear behavior that highly nonlinear
behavior and the retrograde performance
of you ask it to do more work and it
stops getting more work done and even
gets less work done is explained by that
last component that we added to am dolls
law and made it the universal
scalability law so you can click through
there's a an interactive web-based
calculator here if you grab the slides a
little bit later and you can drag some
sliders around and just see how
sensitive this is the the cost of the
coordination or crosstalk pendency grows
really really fast as compared to the
cost of the serialization or queuing
penalty and so that's like the death
knell for any kind of a highly parallel
or system that's designed for
scalability so when you you know you've
probably been at some conferences or
read some papers or something like that
where people say we've designed this
system for linear scalability we you
know made it highly sharded and we can
grow it infinitely well you may be able
to grow it infinitely but you will not
necessarily get linear scalability in
fact very few systems are truly linearly
scalable they may be possible to grow
you know they may not have any fixed
capacity limit on them but what happens
is that as you grow them you will start
paying a huge amount of overhead and you
get this diminishing return on
investment all right so let's see how to
apply this this is all the theory we're
not going to do any more theory let's
see how to apply this in the real world
it turns out to be really really easy we
can take a couple of metrics so I last
night I went grab some metrics from one
of the database servers running in our
system and I grabbed concurrency and
throughput and I have no units I don't
you don't get to see the time scale or
anything here one of these is can
concurrency and one of them is
throughput and they are there's a
variety of of values of these metrics
over time which is good gives us kind of
a spread to work with and the
relationship between these two things
how much do you think I can
can tell from the relationship between
these two things can I predict the the
next presidential election probably not
but what I can tell is how far is the
system going to scale and what is the
primary bottleneck so by doing that or
sorry to accomplish that the first thing
that I want to do is just scatter plot
and the the axes on this scatter plot
are exactly the same as all of the
diagrams that we've been looking at for
a little while as concurrency on the
bottom and throughput on the vertical
axis and that is the u.s. ELLs inputs
and outputs so looking at this is it
linear
looks pretty linear right and one of the
things that we could do is we could just
fit a line to it and see you know holy
cow look at that 97.8% r-squared how
many of you would kill to have a 97.8%
r-squared right you know there's a lot
of data scientists and data engineers in
this room where that's like mind-blowing
ly good fit to align but we shouldn't
celebrate yet because what's not shown
or what's not really obvious on this
chart is that that line is not pointing
at zero comma zero and that is the first
data point in every scalability plot is
that zero zero is always an invisible
implicit point so we have to sort of
include that so this may look very very
linear and usually when people look at
charts like this or when they plot
charts like this and say see this is
linearly scalable this is kind of you
know the the justification for that
conclusion so how bad do you think this
is anybody want to hazard a guess like
is this pretty good or is this system
about to get into deep trouble problem
all right so we have one vote for
problem do we do we have any votes for
this you know this system can actually
scale quite a bit further I see a couple
yeah all right so let's see how it goes
so to answer what we should do is use
regression nonlinear regression and fit
the unit universal scalability law to
this set of points and then let's look
at what it looks like so how many of you
want to change your vote this is
actually a highly nonlinear system can
you believe that if you look at it you
can kind of see maybe what you didn't
see at first that at the left end all of
our points are a little bit below the
line in the middle the points are above
the line at the right end the points are
below the line again that is sort of the
seeds of destruction being sown so this
is what this is what this systems
scalability really looks like and this
is actually pretty clean
and add these these points I took I said
I didn't show you on the previous slides
the the time range that this was taken
over I just took these right out of a
time series database our time series
database at Vivid cortex and I think I
took it over five or seven days so each
of these points there's probably like
300 points each of these points
represents a fairly decent amount of
time you know it's some amount of
minutes maybe it's ten minutes or so
averages so each point each little
circle on here is an average throughput
in an average concurrency over whatever
ten minutes of time and so the system is
actually behaving fairly cleanly and
fits very well to the universal
scalability law and one of the reasons
for that is first of all that the system
is well behaved
and the other is that I've taken those
averages over sufficiently long periods
of time and that we've got a
sufficiently large spread and the data
points to really give us some some room
to fit so if you look at concurrency it
goes from what is it 5 up to 18 or
something like that that's a decent
amount of concurrency range in which to
fit so how much Headroom does this
system have if you just look at this you
know how much further do you think
this system can scale maybe if we had
looked at the linear line we would have
thought that maybe we can get twice as
much work done from this system or
something like that we look at this and
it starts a little bit less less
exciting you know the way that this
chart is plotted there's actually quite
a bit of white space on the horizontal
axis and it looks like we could maybe
you know like double our concurrency or
a load on this system but that's really
an optical illusion just of how I've
chosen to put the axis range I could
have made that go out to a thousand and
it would be sort of an Edward Tufte faux
pas where I'm kind of lying and saying
see the dotted line can go out to a
thousand but what we really see
happening is if if you kind of look at
where this thing starts to taper off and
you can calculate where it tapers off
and so forth and so on but I'm just
doing this with no math I'm just like
drawing some lines on the chart and
going how much Headroom is there and the
reality is there's not much I mean I
don't know what ten twelve fifteen
percent
I've had room before this system is
gonna stop really giving us any payback
under increased load and the bad thing
about this is that as we get out into
the the higher load regions here
this systems utilization is going to get
very high performance is going to go to
hell it is it's going to get highly
variable it's gonna start stalling
performing you know wait times are gonna
you're gonna have outlying latency
outliers and you may even get this
system past a threshold where it gets
stuck and turns into the spiral of death
and it's the kill - nine territory even
you know it gets really really ugly if
we actually push this system to higher
concurrency mostly or if we looked at
shorter term time averages that would
reveal more of the variability that's
kind of averaged away in these points
most likely what we would see is that as
the scatter plot goes to the right it
probably starts to look much less neat
and doesn't lie along the dashed line
very clean cleanly it probably turns
into more of a hairball kind of thrown
on the screen all right so we went from
wow it looks pretty linear to I'm kind
of worried about the system approaching
the
limits of its capabilities in you know a
couple of simple moves alright so that I
think is is actually pretty
transformative take away for capacity
planning where a capacity planning used
to be just sort of our and napkin math
and no real certainty about whether it
was actually going to match the real
world or the insanely hard queuing
theory analysis and things like that you
know we've just taken two simple
measurements from our system throughput
and concurrency and we figured out how
close we are to to the ceiling so let's
see how much further we can take this
not presidential elections but we can do
something really interesting from the
outside of this system treating it like
a total black box we can actually peer
into it like an x-ray and figure out
what's going on inside there even
without knowing anything about the
internals of this system this is fairly
easy to do we can answer the question
what is this system's primary bottleneck
there are two kinds of bottlenecks there
is that serialization penalty where we
get nonlinear scalability because of
things waiting in line and there's the
crosstalk or coherency penalty where we
get non linear scalability because of
things making each other do extra work
so these these parameters in Universal
scalability law have a very real
physical meaning this isn't just you
know picking up parabola and saying you
know I can fit this curve to the points
or something like that there's a real
physical model that this all comes from
and a theoretical basis behind it and
and it does work alright so so I've
listed the physical meaning below here
the throughput of single-threaded miss
that's the slope of our line
we've got Sigma which is just the
fraction of the workload that is
serialized and Kappa the fraction that's
crosstalk and when you regress something
what you're really doing is getting
estimates of the parameters so by
regressing against these points we're
getting estimates of how much
serialization and crosstalk there isn't
it
and this systems parameters are plus or
minus seven and a half percent of
serialization penalty and a very very
small fraction of crosstalk right there
are other systems if you click through
in the references at the ends of these
slides there are lots of other systems
where it's totally the reverse sort of
stereotypically you might see this in a
node.js system that is single threaded
and lots of things are waiting on single
threaded this you might see things that
have a lot of crosstalk penalty in very
heavily multi-threaded systems that have
a lot of overhead of the multi-threaded
nosov a.m. applications spend a lot of
time in thread scheduling and things
like that or in the internal cross
thread communication and so you can see
that really clearly when you do this
regression you know sometimes it's not
but in this case it is and this by the
way this is a MySQL server this is
running in our production systems and
you know it's bottleneck is probably
mutexes just an internal implementation
detail of the database server but it
gets just very nicely kind of teased out
and we separate the wheat from the chaff
and we go if we want this system to
scale better to give us better
performance the one thing that we should
be thinking about is how can we reduce
the contention penalty over
serialization and it might be at the
operating system level it might not be
the database server but that would be
the kind of thing that I would go look
for if I were going to try and make this
thing go faster or go further alright so
who is surprised that you can get that
kind of insight from just taking a
couple of metrics and doing our
regression I know it kind of blew my
mind and so we are at the end and that's
that's all I've got for you today if you
want to scan the QR code you can get
these slides I'll leave that there for
you for a moment
but the next slide after this has some
references that you can
like through - I wrote a little book
about this you can download that for
free from Vivek cortex website there's a
link there and I'm happy to take a
couple of questions and then I should go
to the office hours and probably answer
the rest of the questions there could
you explain the intuition for those
coefficients again where they're coming
from the intuition for the coefficients
okay so the gamma on the top the little
Y looking thing is the if you were to
put N equals 1 in here then everything
kind of disappears from the denominator
all of the components disappear from the
denominator and you just get it reduces
to n over 1 sorry gamma and over 1 and
so gamma is the slope of the line gamma
is the line that goes from 0 0 through
concurrency of 1 and then sorry I guess
I'm doing this kind of in a reverse for
you and and then goes in a linear line
from there and then the the intuition
for Amdahl's law is a little bit
difficult for me to explain kind of
verbally but the idea is that as it
actually it's easier to explain in a
different form of Amdahl's law but it
does when you rearrange the algebra it
it rearranges into this n minus 1
component on the bottom and then the
intuition for the Kappa component is
that the possible amount of Kappa
crosstalk is the n times n minus 1
number of potential interactions between
things doing work concurrently
[Music]